happy for Matt R and his career I am
surprised by the special and I maybe saw
5 minutes of it it's not my thing it's
not for me his audience was like you
know young girls and middle-aged girls
and older girls and what's fascinating
to me is in this special he's like no
I'm for guys now this special is for
guys and it's clearly like he's I've
never seen someone so try to piss off
their their existing audience to try to
grasp at what he thinks should be a
comedian's audience the Shane Gillis
fans of the world are not going to be
like oh a domestic violence joke this
guy's for me too but he's so trying to
like no I'm for guys now I'm a real
comic for dudes it gives me a little bit
of a feeling of Iggy zelia trying to
Freestyle and people who are mad at Matt
R they're like oh he's just like he just
goes to the gym hey get your fat ass to
the gym then if you got it flaun it